[Music]
if you're the kind of person who likes
to use steam to play video games then
you might notice a whole lot more in the
coming months valve is set to remove
steam greenlight this spring and allow
developers to release games directly I'm
Matt this is a game spot news update and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
news from the world of PC gaming
greenlight was rolled out in 2012 as a
replacement for the system valve
previously used for choosing which games
to allow on Steam it's presented more
opportunities for developers to release
their work but it's also been a source
of complaints from both players and devs
velvet knowledge is this saying after
the launch of steam greenlight we
realized that it was a useful stepping
stone for moving to a more direct
distribution system but it still left us
short of that goal along the way it
helped us lower the barrier to
publishing for many developers while
delivering many great new games to steam
there are now over 100 greenlight titles
that have made at least 1 million
dollars each and many of those would
likely not have been published in the
old heavily curated steam store valve is
replacing dream late with something
called steam direct which will let
developers release their games directly
after going through an application
process they'll have to pay a fee for
each game they want to release but I
will get that paid back at a later date
bill hasn't figured out what that cost
will be but we'll keep you up to date as
more is revealed in the meantime you can
check out the making of dishonored tues
best level a crack in the slab
you